Ніколи ми Харків не здамо. Це дурниця все.
Харків, як був, є і буде завжди українським і європейським містом.
Не потрібно це, знаєте, кожного разу жувати, жувати, жувати! Ні. Все!
Прийде час, всі перейдемо на українську мову!
Війна дуже багато перевернула в ментальності харків'ян.
Харків до початку війни ментально і Харків сьогодні – це різний Харків.
Оці, знаєте, навіть важко сказати, що це люди, які наводять ракети, коли вбивають людей.
Важко їх назвати людьми.
До якого 2024 року ви готуєтесь?
Я повинен вам казати правду. Початок року буде дуже складний.
Сьогодні спілкуємося з міським головою Харкова, Ігорем Тереховим. Пане Ігоре, вітаю вас.
Вітаю.
Ми зараз з вами спілкуємося в кабінеті вашому,
але не у міськраді, тому що туди був "приліт" під час повномасштабної війни.
Кажуть, що у вас є кілька офісів в часи війни. Для чого вони вам потрібні?
Ну, насправді так і є. На жаль, сьогодні я не можу розташовуватися
в одному приміщенні, в одному офісі.
І ви знаєте, що був приліт в мерію у минулому році.
На жаль, постраждала мерія.
Крім цього, я певний час знаходився в одній будівлі.
Потім біля неї були прильоти С-300.
Бо, на жаль, сьогодні є певне полювання за мною як міським головою.
І це я розумію. Тому мені рекомендували, щоб було декілька офісів.
Наразі на території Харківщини ведуться тяжкі бої на фронті поблизу Куп'янська.
В цих умовах яка роль Харкова?
Що стосується ролі Харкова, то велика роль Харкова,
бо ми приймаємо вимушених переселенців.
Вчора я був в одному з гуртожитків, де були вимушені переселенці з Куп'янська і діти з Куп'янська.
І ми обслуговуємо людей, і надаємо всі послуги, і навчаємо дітей.
І працевлаштовуємо цих людей, які були вимушені переїхати, бо в них нічого нема.
Тому для нас дуже важливо сьогодні.
І це, до речі, не тільки з Куп'янська.
Сьогодні у Харкові перебуває 191 тисяча вимушених переселенців. Це статистичні дані.
І це Донецька область, Луганська область, Запорізька область, Херсонська область, де окуповані території.
Чи спілкуєтесь ви наразі з військовими про можливу загрозу для самого міста Харків у даних умовах?
Що стосується загрози для Харкова, то я не можу сказати, що у росіян в голові.
І ніхто не може сказати.
І не головне, які в них плани. Головне, які плани у нас.
І ніколи ми Харків не здамо. Це дурниця все.
Харків, як був, є і буде завжди українським і європейським містом. Це головне.
І ми відстояли Харків і будемо відстоювати його.
У дослідженні нещодавньому "Форбс" Харків потрапив у список міст,
які взагалі не виділяють бюджетних коштів за статтею саме тероборони.
За це на міськраду, на вас особисто посипалася критика.
Поясніть нам, нашим глядачам, за якою логікою в цьому році відбувається фінансування Збройних Сил України?
На сьогодні ми за цей період, який з 1 січня 2023 року,
по теперішній час виділили 494 мільйони гривень.
І це кошти, це паливо, це матеріали, які необхідні для військових.
Але я хочу сказати, що я спілкуюся постійно з військовими,
і ви знаєте, що коли з'явилася ця публікація, наша славетна 92-га бригада,
мотострілкова бригада, яким ми допомагаємо грошима,
вони виставили у себе на сторінці обурення тим, що трапилося.
Я вважаю, що це помилка, не хочу це коментувати.
Ми перераховуємо кошти, тільки сьогодні платіж 10 млн грв ми перерахували і будемо перераховувати.
На що саме?
На військові частини.
Ми домовились так, що ми даємо кошти.
Ми не купуємо, купують самі військові, бо вони розуміють, що їм потрібно зараз,
негайно потрібно, а ми видаляємо кошти.
А чи підтримуєте ви нещодавно ухвалену ініціативу про обов'язкове вилучення
з місцевих бюджетів ось цього військового ПДФО, цієї частки, на потреби ЗСУ?
Ми повинні розуміти, що йде війна.
Я ставлюся до вилучення цього ПДФО по-державницькому.
І вважаю, що сьогодні, якщо ми не будемо перераховувати це ПДФО на військових,
то у нас не буде можливості сьогодні швидше перемогти.
Ваш колега, міський голова Києва Віталій Кличко
нещодавно в німецькому відданні Der Spiegel дав таке інтерв'ю,
де заявив, що Україна, цитую, "рухається до авторитаризму,
демократія перебуває під загрозою".
На його думку, цитата: "чиниться величезний тиск на органи місцевого самоврядування".
Як мер Харкова, чи відчуваєте Ви от подібний такий тиск з боку центральної влади?
Ви знаєте, я декілька разів спілкувався з, як Ви кажете, з моїм колегою, мером міста Києва.
І у нас точки зору щодо цієї проблематики відрізняються один від одного.
Ми спілкувалися у Сполучених Штатах на цю тему.
Я не бачу сьогодні, що є якийсь, знаєте, тиск на демократію чи органи місцевого самоврядування.
Навпаки, хочу сказати, що ми, ми маємо безпрецедентну підтримку сьогодні і уряду,
і нашого президента Володимира Зеленського, і Офісу президента, сьогодні нам допомагають.
Харків - прикордонне місто. І сьогодні нам не до політики, не до політики.
І те, що нас підтримують - це головне.
Як часто ви як мер Харкова на зв'язку з Офісом президента, з Володимиром Зеленським?
Останній раз я спілкувався під час його візиту у місто Харків.
Це було минулого тижня чи тиждень тому.
Серйозна розмова була. Конструктивна дуже розмова.
Хочу, до речі, сказати, що кожного разу, коли я спілкуюсь, ми дуже конструктивно розмовляємо.
І після цього певні кроки робляться.
І, знаєте, не було таких питань, які би ми не ставили, і щоб вони не вирішувалися.
Щодо вищого політичного керівництва України:
західні аналітики припускають, ніби є певні політичні розколи
між Офісом президента і між головнокомандуючим ЗСУ Залужним.
Ви як людина в політиці з досвідом всередині цієї системи -
чи відчуваєте якісь непорозуміння в нашому політикумі в цьому контексті?
Дивіться. Знаєте, із засобів масової інформації, телеграм-канали, щось кажуть, правда чи неправда.
Я хочу сказати, що у мене немає такої інформації.
Більш того, те, що я бачу, то взаєморозуміння, і під час війни повне взаєморозуміння.
І, як я бачу, довіра один до одного.
Тому, як на мене, це, знаєте, певні провокації, які сьогодні існують на цю тему,
і я б дуже не хотів би, щоб, знаєте, ці провокації, продовжувалися.
Ви самого пана Залуженого особисто знаєте?
Ну, так. Робочі, військові моменти ми обговорюємо.
Є можливість зв'язатися, задати питання один одному,
допомогти один одному, так, це важливо сьогодні.
Я на контакті із Залуженим, із Сирським, із нашими військовими, зі всіма, бо інакше неможливо.
Залужний, йому вже досить багато присвячували характеристик,
епітетів як людині військовій у цей тяжкий час. Як би ви описали його?
Ну, знаєте, я хочу сказати, що він же каже, що головне, що йому не буде соромно.
Цим все сказано. Сьогодні кожен на своєму місці.
Президент, Залужний, Сирський, Офіс президента, Андрій Єрмак, Олексій Кулеба.
Усі, всі працюють сьогодні, кожну хвилину, кожного дня для того,
щоб весь цей державний механізм функціонував, військовий механізм функціонував.
Наразі очільника СБУ Харківщини, пана Дудіна, судять у справі про держзраду.
У той день, 24 лютого, коли вас і очільника Харківської ОВА, пана Синєгубова, виводили з приміщення ОВА,
це було на відео, ви вже тоді розуміли мету дій?
Дивіться, щодо зради, то це може сказати тільки суд.
Я не можу зараз коментувати це, бо йде, як ви казали, судове засідання.
Тому хочу сказати, що коли буде вирок, тоді я буду казати.
Бо в мене є особиста точка зору щодо нього.
Пан Дудін, на своїх промовах під час судових засідань
критично висловлювався щодо вас і пана Синєгубова,
каже, що "в тюрмі вас дуже чекають".
Що ви відповідаєте на ці звинувачення, на цю його поведінку?
Слухайте, ну, він і меми виставляв після приїзду президента, некоректні, як я думаю.
Знаєте, як на мене, хвора людина.
От коли говорять про явища колабораціонізму українців, в тому числі політиків, з РФ,
маю на увазі, під час війни, непоодинокими є реальні кейси з Харківщини:
Борівська, Вовчанська, Куп'янська громада, наведення російських ракет у селі Гроза.
В чому причина цього явища?
Це явище, яке не з сьогодення.
Воно зароджувалось ще десятиріччя тому.
Це явище є тому, що коли були, як я розумію, проводилося вербування людей,
коли їм вбивалося у мозок, що, знаєте, Радянський Союз, що це Росія, що потрібно, щоб так було,
щоб не потрібно було НАТО, щоб ці демократичні процеси не відбувалися.
Хтось піддався, хтось не піддався.
Але оці, знаєте, навіть важко сказати, що це люди, які наводять ракети, коли вбивають людей.
Важко їх назвати людьми. Вони - агенти, російські агенти.
Вони це роблять. На жаль.
Наша головна мета сьогодні - виявляти їх і попереджати всі ці випадки, які можливо.
До 2022 року міська рада Харкова неодноразово потрапляла в скандали щодо зриву декомунізації.
То були суди щодо проспекту Жукова. Чому це було тоді питання проблемне?
Дивіться, насправді, війна дуже багато перевернула в ментальності харків'ян.
Тому Харків до початку війни ментально і Харків сьогодні – це різний Харків.
І нам потрібно це розуміти.
І сьогодні ми не будемо казати за проспект маршала Жукова. Бо те - ті часи.
Сьогодні зовсім по-іншому. І за інші речі.
Що стосується законної декомунізації, так.
Ми сьогодні працюємо над цим. Ми дуже виважено працюємо.
Так, змінюються вулиці, змінюються назви вулиць.
В одному з інтерв'ю розповідали, що поки що вулиці Степана Бандери в Харкові, цитую, "не уявляйте".
Хоча от на Харківщині в Ізюмі вже і Романа Шухевича, і Степана Бандери є вулиці.
Чи цікавилися ви думкою харків'ян щодо цих от конкретних назв як потенційних для вулиць Харкова?
Безумовно цікавився.
Були якісь офіційні думки?
Давайте таким чином. Я менеджер цього міста. Мене обрали люди.
Для того, щоб я відстоював їхній інтерес.
Так, у мене є власна думка і власна позиція, яку я можу донести, яка я доношу до людей. Відкрито кажу.
Що стосується цього питання, хочу сказати, що сьогодні підтримки назви цієї вулиці у Харкові немає.
Ні Шухевича, ні Бандери?
Ні.
Як гадаєте, чому?
Це ми повинні, знаєте, запитати у людей, але поки що не прийшов час.
Чому?
Тому що не на часі. Давайте так. Я буду казати про місто Харків.
Ізюм - це місто, яке від Харкова на відстані знаходиться.
І там своя громада є, територіальна громада.
Там є своє бачення всього, що там робиться.
Вони, я поважаю, дуже поважаю бачення.
Але я буду робити так, як сьогодні це так вважають харків'яни.
І всі розуміють, як потрібно дуже виважено, не дай Боже, не виважено, все проводити і робити.
Бо це Харків. І це дуже така тонка матерія.
Що значить "це Харків"?
Я ж розумію харків'ян, я чую їхні погляди, чую їхні думки, чую їхній настрій. Чую їхні емоції.
Тому, що стосується цих питань, давайте їх поки що відкладемо на інший час.
Але все ж таки вулиці в Харкові перейменовуються, триває процес.
Звісно.
Одна з вулиць Харкова нещодавно отримала назву на честь лідера
добровольчого підрозділу Фрайкор Георгія Тарасенка.
У 2021-му у вас був такий пост, де ви особисто писали,
що члени Фрайкору провели урок у школі з харківськими дітьми.
Назвали тоді цей урок, цитую, "уроком фашизму".
Організацію пов'язали з нацистами. Змінили свою думку?
Я особисто знав Григорія. Ми спілкувалися.
Вже коли мене обрали мером, ми спілкувалися, дуже довгий час спілкувалися.
Під час війни спілкувалися.
На жаль, я був на його похоронах і спілкувався потім з його батьками і нареченою. На жаль.
Я відповім вам таким чином.
Я особисто вносив цю пропозицію на розгляд сесії, особисто голосував,
щоб присвоїти вулицю, одну з центральних вулиць міста, на його честь.
За даними соціологічного опитування "Рейтинг" в 2023 році
ви очолили список мерів українських міст, яких найбільше схвалюють містяни.
Чому інші мери міст України могли б у вас повчитись, як гадаєте?
Кожен на своєму місці. Кожен робить все, що можливо. І війна це довела.
І я мав безпрецедентну підтримку сьогодні мерів інших міст.
І мерів міст, які є нашими містами-побратими. І не тільки міста-побратими.
І наших міст українських. До речі, тих мерів, кого я до війни навіть не знав.
Наприклад, хто?
Мер Коломиї, наприклад.
Який сам зателефонував, потім приїжджав декілька разів, передавав нам продукти харчування,
медикаменти, речі різні. Ну, я з усіма спілкуюсь.
Чи були якісь розчарування під час повномасштабної війни для вас серед очільників українських міст?
На жаль, були розчарування серед міст, які знаходились у Харківській області, яких я знав.
Але вони на тому боці, це виявилося несподівано для мене. Відверто кажу.
Балаклія. Для мене це був жахливий випадок.
Не очікували саме від Балаклії?
Я не очікував. Ні, ніколи. Ніколи. Для мене це було дуже, знаєте, вразливо.
Ну, я його знав дуже багато років.
Покійного мира Харкова Геннадія Кернеса ви публічно називали другом, соратником у політиці.
Наразі існує ситуація з його сином Кирилом.
Звинувачує вас, мовляв, було, цитую, захоплення влади у 2020 році
і підробка підпису Геннадія Кернеса у періоді його хвороби перед смертю.
Це одна з його останніх заяв в кінці листопада.
Як ви коментуєте ці звинувачення? Чи спілкувалися з ним про це?
Я хочу вам сказати, що, на жаль, після того, як пішов з життя мій друг, я це можу ще й повторити,
Геннадій Кернес, я став секретарем міськради,
і це було рішення депутатського корпусу.
І не я, а Верховна Рада прийняла рішення щодо проведення
позачергових виборів Харківського міського голови, на котрих я здобув перемогу у першому турі.
За мене проголосували харків'яни. А про яке захоплення влади має йти мова?
Ви публічно почали спілкуватись українською зараз.
Ще є над чим працювати.
Ви почали спілкуватися після повномасштабної війни.
Що стало ось тим моментом, коли ви зрозуміли: "Ну все, від завтра я вже беруся за це"?
Ні, дивіться, насправді я дуже хотів спілкуватися українською мовою,
але знаєте, до війни, на жаль, на жаль, так сталося, що ми спілкувалися слобожанською мовою,
і тому я хотів перейти на українську мову, щоб мені не було соромно.
Вам особисто за себе?
Так. Я не можу розмовляти через слово, знаєте, слобожанська, українська, чи вимовляти щось не так.
Для мене це потрібно, перш за все, для мене.
Тому я хочу розмовляти справжньою українською мовою.
І я дуже, моя мета розмовляти справжньою українською мовою.
Чи відчуваєте, що Харків став, можливо, більш україномовним?
Так, звісно. Харків набагато став україномовним.
І сьогодні, знаєте, коли ти йдеш, тебе вітають "доброго дня" чи "вітаю".
Раніше було "здрастє", "прівєт". Тому ні.
І люди хочуть переходити. Я бачу, молодь вся хоче переходити.
Тому, знаєте, я чому тоді казав, що не потрібно наламати дров.
І дуже виважена політика повинна бути у всьому, що стосується Харкова.
А от чи може місцева влада впливати якось на українізацію російськомовних українців?
Потрібно розмовляти, ну, у тому числі українською мовою.
І це, от, я вважаю, і весь світ вважає, що ми довели, що Харків, що ми українське місто.
І будемо назавжди українським містом. І не зустрічали тут росіян з квітами!
А зустрічали гранатами, мінометами, кулями. І все. Крапка.
Не потрібно це, знаєте, кожного разу жувати, жувати, жувати. Ні. Все.
Ми довели всьому світу, що ми українське місто.
Ми справжні українці. І потихеньку мова буде.
Ну прийде час, всі перейдемо на українську мову.
Як думаєте, скільки років?
Повністю? Десять років!
Війна наскільки відкинула розвиток Харкова?
На жаль, відкинула, але дала певні можливості.
І знаєте, я оптиміст, хочу сказати.
Я вважаю, що так, дуже серйозні виклики, які ми проходимо, вони і дають нам можливості.
Дуже багато сьогодні у нас є можливостей разом з міжнародними фінансовими інституціями.
З різними нашими міжнародними партнерами.
Перезапустити економіку міста. Зробити місто зовсім іншим.
А наразі відтік бізнесу, наприклад, наскільки вплинув на Харків зараз?
Ми чотири хвилі повернення пережили.
І сьогодні хочу сказати, що буквально вчора ми дивились за відкриттям ФОПів у нас позитивна динаміка.
Позитивна динаміка. Плюс дві тисячі з порівнянням з до війни.
А чи безпечно наразі українцям, які виїхали з Харкова через війну, повертатися у місто?
Кожен для себе приймає це рішення. Кожен
Бо це його особиста відповідальність. Безпечно чи небезпечно,
подивіться скільки прильотів за місяць було по Києву, по Львову, по Черкасам і по Харкову.
Скільки зараз проживає в Харкові людей? Є якась статистика?
Є статистика. У нас мільйон триста сьогодні перебуває в місті Харків.
І це люди і харків'яни, і ті, котрі вимушені були переїхати з деокупованих територій, з інших міст і областей України.
Але якщо порівняти з березнем 2022 року, коли у нас було триста тисяч,
і сьогодні на мільйон більше, ніж тоді, то ви розумієте, що я дуже радий.
Як Харків планує заохочувати людей, які ще не повернулися, десь ще релоковані, повертатися?
Головне, перше, це безпекова ситуація. І ми повинні це розуміти.
Відкриття шкіл, дитячих садочків, наших вишів.
Є в мене чіткий план дій, що потрібно зробити для того, щоб, знаєте, залучати інвестиції,
щоб залучати підприємців, щоб вони поверталися, щоб нові підприємці поверталися у місто.
Бо конкуренція між містами буде дуже велика.
Зараз є?
І зараз є. Зараз вона, знаєте, така скрита конкуренція.
Всі міста між собою будуть конкурувати. Всі.
За інвестиції, за кадровий потенціал, за людей.
За все буде шалена конкуренція. І ми повинні виграти цю конкуренцію.
Головний конкурент буде, звісно, Київ. Завжди так було.
Київ, Львів. Ці будуть конкуренти. Десь Дніпро буде.
У Харкові, ви згадали, до речі, працює підземна школа.
Метро-школа, як назвали журналісти.
Анонсовано вже з січня і метро-садочок.
Підготовка на метро-садочок.
От наскільки, проаналізувавши вже досвід роботи цих шкіл на станціях, ефективність,
зручність для самих дітей, для вчителів, для пасажирів метро? Який цей досвід?
Ну, що стосується пасажирів, ми не заважаємо пасажирам. Ми так зробили це.
Що стосується дітей, знаєте, я тільки що проводив зустріч.
Дуже, до речі, дуже таку цікаву. Цікаву зустріч, яку я мав з людьми.
І вони дуже підтримують цю мою ідею щодо організації метро-школи.
І хочу вам сказати цифри, ви все зрозумієте.
1 вересня, коли школярі пішли до метро-школи, їх налічувалося десь 890 дітей.
Сьогодні 2108, і немає жодного вільного місця, а запит на місця є.
Але у нас немає потужності і можливості.
Тому ми сьогодні будуємо вже, і я розраховую до кінця січня побудувати справжню підземну школу на 450 учнів.
Тобто в дві зміни будуть займатися 900 учнів.
У одному районі міста. Такі школи будуть з'являтися у всіх районах міста Харкова. До речі, їх 9, нагадаю вам.
Вони будуть з'являтися для того, щоб діти мали змогу повноцінно навчатися.
Відбудова Харкова глобальна: вже була зацікавленість відомого британського архітектора Лорда Нормана Фостера.
Не зацікавленість, ми працюємо.
Вже робота йде?
Не те, що йде, вона йде дуже швидко.
Є конкретні рішення?
Так, є конкретне рішення. Я на засіданні фонду презентував 5 проєктів пілотних щодо наукового парку,
щодо вокзалу, щодо центральної частини, щодо житлової забудови.
Не витрачаю кошти, до речі, не витрачаю кошти міста Харкова. Це кошти сім'ї Лорда Фостера.
Ви маєте на увазі розробка генплану?
Так, розробка генплану. І нам допомагає дуже німецький уряд. З цим проєктом.
А фінансування на відбудову?
Фінансування міжнародне, фінансування, звісно, саме місто не зможе все зробити.
І, знаєте, ми підрахували так приблизно, приблизно, що, щоб відбудувати все це, що накоїв поки що наш ворог,
російський агресор, 9,5 мільярдів доларів США.
Звісно, ніякий бюджет такого не може витримати.
Тому це міжнародне фінансування інституцій.
Це EBRD, ще Світовий банк. Тому дуже важливі, такі потужні банки.
Крім цього, хочу сказати, що, що стосується країн, то ми маємо безпрецедентну підтримку Німеччини.
І я вдячний, і я декілька разів зустрічався із урядовцями,
високопосадовцями Німеччини і послами Німеччини.
Ми маємо підтримку, ми маємо підтримку Великобританії сьогодні, інших держав, і Польща нам допомагає.
Ви згадували щойно про міжнародну співпрацю, про міжнародну підтримку українського міста Харків.
Але от майбутнє України в Європі, в ЄС наразі вирішується.
В ЄС ми повинні бути, обов'язково повинні бути.
Тому потрібно, знаєте, докласти всіх зусиль, всі.
Дипломатичні, міжнародні. Дружні, у тому числі, стосунки для того. Муніципальні, до речі, стосунки.
Бо дуже багато впливових мерів. Дуже багато впливових мерів у різних країнах. І їх потрібно використовувати.
І ми будемо використовувати всі свої стосунки, всі свої можливості для найшвидшого вступу до ЄС.
До якого 2024 року ви готуєтесь? Яким ви його чекаєте?
Ну, я хочу сказати, безумовно, знаєте, у нас же відверта розмова.
Я повинен вам казати правду. Початок року буде дуже складний.
Дуже складний, бо ми увійшли в опалювальний сезон.
Є певна загроза енергетичної безпеки, ми це розуміємо всі.
Але ми витримаємо. Витримаємо. Переживемо.
Бо були часи дуже важкі. І переможемо.
Я дуже хочу, щоб 2024 рік став переможним для України.
Дуже дякую вам за цю розмову.
Дякую вам.